like i've been doing jk news since you
guys started but i was only here
whenever i had a pocket i wasn't really
here very much i was here when you know
you weren't here before you you weren't
here he was here whenever we couldn't
find another guest yet that's true when
we wanted someone to play a gay guy he
was here you're here for what 12 hours
before me i was here for like [ __ ]
2700 hours and that's when the [ __ ]
started going down and everybody started
quitting and so they had because i think
that energy was well because of me
and then when i came on things started
picking up and there's like regular the
vibe is cool yeah another views more
than ever
dancers brought all the sentiment in a
lot of logic practicalities alien at the
audience they made people worse
otherwise everybody would have thought
this was just a republican group that
sports trump but now the answers here
you know that's not no i think that's
like really cool and i think that you
were really thankful for what we're
doing now the dancers are here that
people throwing paint on the car they're
like why did you leave it to the dancers
and then you made us all lose on luna
yeah i made you lose a little yeah
that's a huge thing i told you to cash
out don't even start on omg with these
guys you know what i mean two fails
right i can't believe we're still
friends omg the bull market the first
one that went that multiply [ __ ]